tonight the president begins a series of
11 rallies in six days leading up to the
midterm elections health care is a top
issue for voters across the country
including Florida now our battleground
tracker poll found three out of four
Floridians say it's very important to
their vote just ahead of the economy
Nancy Cordes is in Miami Beach with more
on this story Nancy good morning good
morning and here in Florida and really
around the country health care has been
a huge part of the closing argument for
both parties but especially for
Democrats who have been looking at the
polling for months and believe that the
party in power is vulnerable on this
issue I believe that health care should
be a right turn on the TV and it's not
hard to spot the Democratic message Ted
Cruz has voted to take away health care
from millions of American families now
the threat is Patrick morsi's lawsuit to
take away health care over the past two
months more than half of all Democratic
ads in federal races mentioned health
care highlighting GOP opposition to
Obamacare the eyes of 217 days or 213 as
the law's popularity has bounced back
from a low in 2013 professor at
community health of South Florida
Obamacare led to a drop in the rate of
uninsured patients from 70% to 50% once
they got coverage they were able to come
a lot more often with a closer follow-up
have better control of their diseases
the clinic is located in Florida's 26th
district represented by Republican
Carlos Carmelo his Democratic challenger
has hammered him on Obamacare he
actually voted to repeal the Affordable
Care Act in a district where we have the
second largest number of people enrolled
in the ACA rabello argues premiums are
still rising too fast and that the GOP
plan would have been better if you
had been successful in repealing and
replacing Obamacare what would have
happened to all the people here in your
district who rely on they would be part
of a health care system that's more
coherent and we would be on a more
sustainable path towards
better healthcare in our country
president Trump is campaigning for
Republicans here in Florida today he's
been trying to change the conversation
to immigration an issue where
Republicans think gale that they have
the edge all right Nancy thank you very
much CBS News live coverage of the
midterm elections begins on CBS n next
Tuesday at 5:00 p.m. war clock central
and we'll all be here for a primetime
election night special really looking
forward to this starting at 9:00 8:00
central right here on CBS